you are 22 years old you were entering  first of all some of the greatest years  of your life a but B you have to  understand this next five year window is  when you don't go practical and safe  this is not the time to get the job Mom  wanted you to this is not the time to  try to maximize as much money so you can  buy a a fat whip this is when you need  to attack what you love and what you  want to do here's why you don't have all  the baggage you may have the  expectations of your parents you may  have a lot of other things do you  understand this is not when the baby's  there this is not when the world has  sucked out all your dreams and hopes yet  it's harder for the 42 year olds that  are watching right now to listen to this  advice you can't just wake up tomorrow  and be like let's go because Little  Sally has soccer [ __ ] practice this  is when you put in the 18 hours a day to  make your life that you want happen this  is when you can grind at your highest  levels